when the pigment family moves into their
dream house that future seems bright
until the ghost of a troubled child and
truths unearthly visions and violent
attacks exposing anvil force and fury
brewing for centuries
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're back once again this is episode 67
that's right yeah and we're getting back
to the the haunting series yeah yeah we
figured we hadn't done one of those in a
while like I said I've been trying to
kind of switch out true-crime and
paranormal and stuff like that so since
it was time to do another paranormal why
don't we thought well we haven't done
done an episode of haunting for a long
time so let's do one of those like I had
actually scheduled it for a lady but we
decided to do with this and we're gonna
do Sally's house yes hmm
and this is actually a very famous case
I'm not entirely clear on whether the
house was famously haunted before these
people moved in that were on haunting or
if it was known around town as being
haunted before that why do you bring it
up
I'm just saying since it's like such a
well-known haunted house yeah nowadays
okay you don't know you're so I don't
know if it stemmed from the early I mean
cuz the haunting was not the first thing
that this couple were on were not the
first TV show that they were on like
about this haunting so but we'll get
into that a little bit later it was a
season 1 episode and probably one of the
most famous ones yeah so we'll kind of
talk about the house and how it kind of
differed from you know the real story
quote-unquote as it's known and so you
were able to dig up some more on this a
little bit yeah there's you know like I
said there's all of these it's just like
kind of he-said she-said so you're just
kind of going by what I put on various
perks and then we can give our
commentary and analysis of this case so
let's go ahead and do the little plugs
and get that stuff out of the way and
look at it yeah not really anything
super extensive this week just kind of
like plugging my book the faceless
villain out of print and ebook I finally
uploaded the audiobook it will be ready
so yeah if it if it goes through the
quality control okay it should be on
sale in about ten days from now or ten
ten to fourteen days usually and then
we'll we'll figure out a way to get
everybody
who's asked for a copy of this to get
either your codes yeah we're gonna do
the patreon patrons first do you know
how that we're gonna contact them should
we contact them through Patriot do
Patriot I can just send a message on
there and I'll give you a code if you
want it right so if you sent me a
message before about wanting a code and
stuff like that I have a list but just
remind me just in case you know I left
someone off or something like that so I
can make sure that everybody that wanted
a code gets one because like I said I
only get 25 so it's kind of first-come
first-serve also we would like to thank
our newest patreon patron whose name is
and I'm hope I'm pronouncing this right
is gem in or jamming okay it's just um
so yeah okay or at the end my that to
probably yeah man um so thank you to
that is our that is our latest patron
also we just did another movie review on
the Michael Caine movie the hand man for
1981 yes was that you know we really
liked that movie from our childhood
people seem to be enjoying us so far
yeah so go check that out if you haven't
already and also as I usually say um go
check out our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
if you would rather give a one-time
donation just go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com and there
is a little link in the sidebar to a
paypal where you can give a donation if
you would like to do that we are always
looking for new patrons yes we are yes
and we love all trying to reach our goal
of $1000 a month yeah that'd be nice to
you but I don't think okay I'm no that's
okay alright so anyway we're talking
about the Sally's house haunting and
mostly specifically about you know about
the haunting episode that they made
about it from season one although it
should be noted that I believe the first
TV show that was made about this case
was actually the show sightings and that
came out in the mid 90s yeah I remember
that's Jeff yeah we yeah it was only
which was right around the time like it
was right around the
that this couple lived in this house as
they moved in the house in 1993 so
sightings was actually the first show to
talk about it and then a haunting did it
I don't did paranormal witness to it I
don't think so I kind of wanted to say
that they did but maybe not now that
you're mentioned all these little series
I'm wonder if you can get them on DVD oh
I'm sure you can
well I think sightings was actually
pretty popular wasn't it yeah I remember
uh what was the other one that had
Richard stack and those named Richard
Roberts Roberts dad unselfish unsolved
mysteries that went on for what like 20
see that [ __ ] had to be like okay if the
thing about unsolved mysteries is I
think that Robert Stack made essentially
an infinite number of episodes okay yeah
because every time because I've seen
like a bunch of the shows and reruns I
used to watch them you never see the
same one and I've never seen the same
one twice that was a good series though
cuz you never knew what was gonna be
sometimes just disappearances and stuff
like that yeah like like most of them
weren't paranormal but it's like you
know I like creepy unsolved murders they
have like no really good you have folk
cases on there that yeah really yeah I
have really heard from sense you know
yeah but uh yeah I bet you they do have
some DVDs of those I'm sure they
probably do I don't even know how long
that was on I think it was almost 30
years but yeah so the show sightings
actually covered this case after the
haunting episode came out I don't know
if there was a paranormal witness I kind
of think there wasn't Navasota but the
house subsequently became very famous
for being haunted and so it has
subsequently been featured on I think
Ghost Adventures went there and all that
kind of stuff like I kind of saw the
ghost adventures episode about this
house yeah and I was kind of like well I
should probably watch it but I have a
hard time sitting through events like
two people that are like fans of the
show but yeah I just I find it really
tedious and they're always just kind of
like hey did you feel that and I you
know I'm like no we can't feel that I
don't know what the demographic gets
marketed towards us single mothers at
home raising children
actually I mean like I said who watches
that it's not even like at least a
haunting has like reenactments and is
like at least there's something
happening right even if you think it's
[ __ ] I mean at least it's
entertaining like the way a ghost
stories entertain here a little horror
like the way a killing Bigfoot would be
it's something energy Cuban people like
causing a rift around the trailer is
just recognized rednecks and cabochon
pit into like bunkers and closing the
lid screen on top of them with shotguns
and stuff like that ridiculous
how can they make a whole season out of
that oh I never find out around I never
could bring myself to watch his like job
even though it's kind of curious but
yeah but truck over here put them lights
on there's that Bigfoot no that's just
her oh yeah but yeah so you know a
haunting paranormal witness like I said
at least it has you could watch it as
though it was a fictional ghost story
because their [ __ ] actually happening
whereas Ghost Adventures it's just a
bunch of dudes wandering around a
abandoned building and with night-vision
cameras pretending like they're
investigating pretending like they're
hearing things and or they're feeling
people touch them and stuff it's just
not that compelling you know I'm sorry
about that
but they did go and explore this house
because like I said subsequently this
house is generally on most lists of the
quote-unquote most haunted houses in
America for sure
considered the most haunted house in
Kansas where it is it's in a chastened
Kansas and so you know it's now it's the
subject of a lot of ghost tours and
stuff like that and you can easily find
it it's yet 508 North Street or
something like that there's pictures of
it all over the internet like the house
it's looks similar to the one that they
put it in a haunting so basically the
story of the haunting it's Deb and Tony
Pickman and they move into this house in
I believe was March of 1993 yes Deb was
pregnant at the time yeah about three
months after they move in she has the
baby the baby's name is Taylor and at
first you know there wasn't much weird
going on I think the first
they noticed was the TV going off and on
that's right TV going off and on which
you know it thought it was bad wiring
yeah which she would like you know ours
did that for a while - isn't it wasn't
that weird yeah it was pretty weird
yeah hasn't done in a long time well we
don't know TV we don't have that TV in
the living room is right
who strange thing about the one in our
house is that it never did it and none
of the other TVs in the house did it not
better to remember oh one time yeah in
the middle of the night it turned off
that's right yeah but that was the only
time it did it I think it do it twice
okay the one in the living room is like
pretty much every other day and it did
it in this other side room over here a
couple times but it was weird I talked
to the cable company the Direct TV
company about it yeah they came to fix
something unrelated unrelated and not
told him about it they they just looked
at me like I like no it's like yeah you
know like yeah yeah and John by itself
all the time all the time that one out
there did and that was during during the
time that other stuff was going on yeah
we haven't really noticed anything weird
for a long time that's been a while it's
kind of like you know work the kinks out
or something I'm not as on edge as I was
yeah that period maybe yeah maybe that's
where that we were right in poltergeist
books during that time well you're
talking about it all about him that's
why I kept saying you wanted to see it
and it would it would manifest itself in
certain ways yeah that's true so maybe
the more we talk to the hand
hand was popping up yeah nevermind what
I remember what the hand did to Michael
Caine jumped up his pant leg grabbed
about it nuts briefly yeah then like I
think that didn't happen to me it
would've been funny for me to watch my
not so funny for you know yes so the
first thing they notice was TV going on
off and on by itself
and they were just like whatevs it's you
know we'll call an electrician or
whatever now the next thing they notice
is that they go up into the nursery yeah
and there are a bunch of stuffed animals
and they're sitting on the floor in a
circle
yeah facing outward like a like they're
having a little pagan teddy bear right
yeah okay well at first they're kind of
like oh that's weird they
blame each other of doing it because at
this point you know the baby's been born
and Deb's sister has come for a week to
visit so she's staying with them to help
out or whatever so all three of them see
this now they're at first they're
blaming so like did you do that I didn't
do that I've been with you all day [ __ ]
off and stuff like that so at first they
think that it's Tony's brother who lives
next door
um sneaking into the house and [ __ ]
up their [ __ ] like Brooke to freak him
out cuz apparently they said oh they're
pranksters and they played tricks on
each other all the time so that's at
first what they thought it was so then
they put all the toys away and then they
leave the room and according to them it
was only a few minutes later and Tony is
walking past the nursery again and all
the stuffed animals are on the floor
sitting in a circle again yeah this is
very reminiscent of my poltergeist
that's what I was saying that is Mary
mind that is very much like [ __ ] that
happened in you yeah in Mammoth monix if
it would do it for hours or days on end
yeah like clockwork and it would even
like turn lights off and on it to tell
you when to look into the room or window
look so when I first heard that I was
thinking you know the first time I saw
this episode I was like poltergeist and
then I started to wonder if whether or
not you know she had just given birth
made me wonder if pregnant a young
pregnant woman maybe because of hormonal
imbalances may initiate some kind of a
poltergeist phenomena I started to think
that it's weird as the phenomenon
continues it may be not yeah it seems to
get more ghost-like but it starts out
very poltergeist light but a poltergeist
is a fake ghost it can impersonate a
host for a long time and it'll been
person anything you think it is yeah I'm
not entirely convinced that this was
ghost 2 even to this day yeah I think it
might have been poltergeist the only
thing that would convince me otherwise
is whether or not these people left this
house and then at a later date other
people came to the same location and
witnessed it again right then that means
it's not related to the people it's
related to the location so I would say
interactive haunting but I don't know
was there any other information you were
able to do now evidently some other
ghosts like paranormal investigators
that went there after word like in
subsequent years because these this
couple was only there they were there
for less than two years okay you know
and after they
left in the butt and Deb pikmin
eventually wrote a book about it which
was which is called Sally house so I
think it kind of got a lot of gained a
lot of steam from that so evidently some
paranormal groups I've seen some videos
on YouTube and stuff like that that say
they've picked up EVPs there that that's
a big thing that they've got like
photographic anomalies that sort of [ __ ]
yeah that's not the same as moving
objects right so I don't really know
couple witnesses like in this case I'm
gonna go ahead and say right now this
based on the way the phenomenon started
and the way it's described throughout
this case I'm gonna say this is a
poltergeist a classic poltergeist case
our spk risk-return spontaneous
psychokinesis
by the subconscious you know I'm just
gonna say that that's what I think it is
yeah all right all right but okay ya can
do this there's a ghost case that's the
way a haunting does well yeah that's
what they'd okay but okay so like I said
these toys are moving around at first
they think the brother is doing it so
the brother is over at the house and
they're like hey had what do you been
doing climbing in the window or
something like that that brothers like
what's [ __ ] you talking about it's
like I was even home that day it's like
it wasn't me then you know the the
brother starts joking around saying no
what do you think your [ __ ] house is
haunted or something like that and then
he starts going around I don't know if
it looked like the nursery but I guess
it was the living room but he goes
around starts taking pictures like
jokingly yeah and evidently he sees a
teddy bear that was sitting on a chair
come flying off by itself it just sounds
like Pulver guys dressed so they were
all kind of like okay [ __ ] this [ __ ] so
you know fair play to them all this is
all that's happened so far just teddy
bears moving around by themselves and
they said okay well we're gonna leave
the house for a little while because
this is kind of freaking us out right so
they went to I think it was Tony's
parents house for a little while now
they said okay we hung out there and we
were kind of freaked out by it now while
Tony is putting the baby in the car he
says he feels something on his back he
said it felt like a bee sting but he's
like you know we were all kind of
flipping out and everything so I didn't
really think that much about it but when
they get to Tony's parents house I guess
Deb like kind of touches his back or
something like that and he's like oh man
you know the thing bit me or say like
she lifts his shirt up and there are the
tell-tale three scratch marks now
familiar on his back yeah which also
happened on you in your case oh they're
not on a body it happened to happen on a
door front door frame yeah and it ripped
the lock the chain to the door of the
door chain yeah and it's funny as it's
never for and it's number two
yeah i guess cuz ii wouldn't really look
like a clog for is one one scratch extra
you don't actually have to have four to
make it look like a claw mark yeah if
it's three that's a minimum amount to
make it look like a crow mark yeah so
maybe that's a conserving energy is
awesome like okay some paranormal
researchers say it's three because it's
a mocking of the Trinity now how about
those I don't buy that but it always
does seem to be three so apparent so
there's three big scratch marks on his
back so at this point they're just kind
of like okay well obviously something
weird is going on in this house so then
the brother says my boss's sister is
like a psychic or like a parapsychology
lecturer or something like that so why
don't you have her come to the house and
you know see if she can figure out
what's going on so this woman comes to
the house and she says that she senses a
spirit that's like a little girl that's
like about seven years old yeah and that
her name is Sally you know what I say
yeah I say never bring many of those
psychics into in Aqaba into any kind of
a paranormal situation you want to bring
in an investigator yeah somebody who's
impartial but the thing it's and this
happens on a lot of a haunting episodes
too it's like okay we know a lot of
people right yeah do we know anyone
that's a psychic no do we know anyone
that knows anyone that's a psychic do we
know you know what though there may be
there may be some two-bit psychics in
our on our Friday this and if you could
grab a random one of those you know you
it's you're not gonna get much you lost
it to me it seems kind of weird it's
like maybe these people travel a
different different social circles than
us but it's like it does it seems like
every episode of a haunting they know
somebody that's a psychic or they know
someone that knows someone that's very
out of style or or a Native American
shaman or something like that which is
like where are these people hanging I
think that's
out of style now I can remember running
into tarot card readers and stuff in the
90s and that was that that's the last
time yeah I do feel like that was kind
of bigger about in the day especially in
the goth scene you did get like kind of
a lot of Wiccans computers and internet
have shout holes and all that kind of
stuff you just don't see it anymore but
yeah so yeah so this psychic comes in
and you know tells them about that
there's a little girl and it's a Miss
Sally and she tells Tony the husband to
take pictures around the house the wife
Deb this is actually what makes this
episode kind of unusual is because Deb
is like she finds out about this little
ghost everything and she is super
[ __ ] into it she is like that's
awesome there's like a little girl ghost
in the house because the psychic tells
her oh well the baby or the
the ghost is just trying to protect the
baby which is why the little ghosts
scratched the dad because maybe she
thought the dad was hurting the baby or
something ask me that's another one in
favor of my my hypothesis yeah that she
is the poltergeist focus maybe that's
why she's enjoying it yeah all right
because she just thought that was the
coolest thing because it's generated by
her subconscious maybe that's how I
think it was cuz I was in its certain
part in certain points in mind I was the
same way I would kind of waver between
being terrified or being really
interested in this thing and interacting
with it you know and her husband was
just freaked out by yeah he was like not
really down no it's the whole especially
I mean he was the one that got scratched
yes so he was like not super happy about
situation in general sounds like RSP kid
sounds like poltergeist and I mean they
had just had a baby and then apparently
when this paranormal stuff started
happening a lot of tension started
building up between the two of them
because Deb was like really into was
very positive about the haunting and
Tony was much less so the family's under
a lot of stress they just had a kid
there's financial burdens involved she's
got uh some hormonal imbalances being it
being a new mother and that's I think
kicked off psychic abilities it very
well do that yeah of course like I said
this is always the subconscious that's
doing it yeah telekinesis
so Deb decides well since she thinks
this is such a cool thing that this
kid is here I think actually the psychic
sort of encourages her to you know let
the kids stay it's fine you know she's
you're protecting the baby and
everything like that so Deb goes to the
store to buy the ghost some toys of her
own okay so the psychic has encouraged a
poltergeist focus to go ahead and
indulge in this ghostly fantasy of
having a little child protector spirit
so that's gonna start you so the
poltergeists gonna start manifesting
those type of qualities yeah and more
yes you find out later all right
now one thing I thought was a little bit
weird like Deb goes to the store and she
buys like little teddy bears and stuff
like that that she's gonna give and but
they also put another crib in the
nursery the baby sometimes sleeps in the
crib but usually they put him in a
bassinet in their room just for safety
purposes but I'm like the ghost if it's
really a ghost she's seven seven year
old kids don't sleep in cribs No so I'm
just saying which wouldn't you give her
like a little bed or something I would
think her a little Barbie bed it was
like that you know I can't tell with
these kids with these people man so yeah
now while she's buying the teddy bears
and stuff like that she picks up the
pictures that Tony took while the
psychic was there and now the psychic
evidently told him to take pictures at a
particular place like the psychic was
like oh well I feel her energy at the
top of the stairs so take a picture the
top of the stairs now apparently the
picture that he took and the ones they
showed on the show were obviously not
the real pictures if they never do that
they do on paranormal witness they
actually show the actual [ __ ] yeah but a
haunting they never do yeah because it's
not it's never as cool because that's
what they share as a haunting sucks
no no if you have a love/hate
relationship with a haunting all the
food episodes of the haunting do they
actually show the actual food they
hardly ever do yeah and that was only in
the very beginning like the first series
and they didn't want the audience I
think to come to expect that because so
many of the episodes don't present don't
have any evidence to back them up yeah
they're good it's a good series
especially the first couple seasons I
like it's very comforting to watch
there's something about the soundtrack
and that guy's more isolated
same actors over and over again you know
me they yeah you can sit there just it's
like junk food television you can just
sit there and Connor yes like sometimes
we will put one of the DVDs on and then
just like let it sit on the back end
just like take a nap yeah while we're
just yeah guys are just wandering but
yeah now one of the photos and they kind
of showed like you know a simulated one
in the episode but one of the photos
evidently the real one I believe is
actually on Google if it's the same one
that I saw I'll put it in the YouTube
video it's that one
but apparently yet but apparently this
one was taken by the TV show sightings
in the 90s now it does show the
staircase of the house and there's like
a weird haze fog no that looks pretty
strange yeah it doesn't look like a
person no the one that they showed in a
haunting looked kind of like a person
that that one does that looks a lot
thicker than what I saw yeah at Mammoth
and see how it's not uniformed it's like
the most v-shaped yeah it's like a
v-shaped yeah whenever I saw whenever I
saw it it was just either totally round
up and a seat up near the ceiling in a
corner or it would just cover the whole
ceiling or you'd look down at the end of
the hallway and you'd see an open door
to room in the whole room and be kind of
filled with a slight haze you know what
I mean yeah that looks pretty the thing
is what I saw you wouldn't be able to
photograph it yeah we didn't it wasn't
that pronounced right you know be like
trying to photograph a really light fog
or a mist inside inside a house you know
I mean you know it does look that looks
pretty it's honest looks solid
it almost looks fake TIFF you asked me
almost like somebody put a little smoke
bomb there or something that could be or
did something to the camera lens that
might be something on the camera lens
causing a blur this famous photo that's
right it's actually from the sightings
episode they their crew took this
particular photo so I don't know how
like because like I said in the episode
of a haunting you know Tony took the
phone that's a photo or that's a video
that's a photo I'd like to see the
actual photo before I'd make up my mind
it looks a little pronounced so yeah but
you know in the episode of a haunting
they basically took a whole roll of film
and you know back in the old days kids
you had to take the roll of film to the
one-hour photo yeah or the lab and
that's them yes it sucks it was a
nightmare yeah and you didn't and you
know if you ran out of film or if you're
if your pictures appear oh no and these
were always [ __ ] up and they were
always [ __ ] over always funny and then
yeah so and you wouldn't know until you
went to pick them up and then you'd be
like oh well there's yeah and your
life's trying to take a picture of you
know our wedding and yes one is like you
can always gonna turn out so good and
they would all be bad they come you know
I mean okay you you youngsters would
know that when you're taking a picture
with your phone
half of them pictures are thrown away
cuz the eyes are closed and bad
expressions well back in the day of film
every single shot would be one that you
would throw away yeah out of an entire
roll of film you were lucky to get one
photo that you'd like to keep
yeah they had people in it it was easy
to take pictures of objects and places
yours yeah I took about a zillion
pictures of the [ __ ] camera strap bag
because you couldn't see it when you
were taking the picture but like if your
hand was in the wrong place that kind of
put it in front of the lens like Heaney
and then you would take the picture and
you'd be like that was awesome and then
you get it back and it's just a big blur
yeah I smoked back in those days so half
the time I just got cigarette smoke
[Music]
cigarette burn in your right hand and
the smoke could go out in front of the
damn glances every now and then flash it
every now and then you would get a
really cool like accidentally
atmospheric and awesome picture doing
that
you know 99 times out of 100 it just
didn't look like I need it so you know
that might have been the case for that
but in the episode of a haunting they
took a whole roll of film in every
single picture so they implied on the
show had some kind of anomaly and it had
some kind of fog in it or some kind of
weird like figure or you know none of
them really looked like orbs they all
kind of look like weird shapes or yeah
I'd like to see that could be plausible
in a strong poltergeist case something
like that much yeah so like I said you
know at this point like I said a lot of
tension between the two of them because
Deb is super into it now the decision
can feel poultry oh yeah now she shows
the pictures to him and he's like holy
[ __ ] look at that then her sister and
her sisters husband come over like one
night to hang out or whatever and
they're looking at the pictures going
huh this looks like it's probably not
too good and then so Deb and Tony go in
the kitchen to like finish cooking
dinner or whatever and the sister and
the husband see a teddy bear that's
sitting on the chair catch fire yeah
pyrokinesis right which we just did a
show about a couple yeah that's very
rare to see that in a haunting case yeah
anything involving ghosts how many how
many episodes of pyrokinesis
have ever been reported right in a
haunting case
yeah anko's not many this sounds like
poltergeist it really does yeah
pyrokinesis is just another form of
telekinesis you're not moving of a solid
object you're just moving molecules the
faster you can get molecules moving the
hotter it gets
yeah until flame explodes you know so
they so they put out the teddy bear and
you know Tony's like what the [ __ ] and
they're like oh no the [ __ ] bear just
caught on fire what the hell is that all
about so at this point they're kind of
thinking now I should note that on the
episode of the show they only showed
that happening once yeah later on Deb
said that actually happened a few times
at least three times she's like it was
no recurrence ponton yeah she's like it
was nothing major
she said usually just something would
catch fire like a small thing and then
go oh yeah that's um you know
I only showed it once on the show but
she said it did happen several times
yeah that's typical okay so we are at
the halfway point now so we are going to
take a short break and then we will be
right back talking about the Sallie
house haunting
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
protect the paper and declared at the
end of the day at this house is very
much tortured and will continue to be
honored there may long time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so we're back yep now as I said at
this point Deb is still believing that
this is a little girl and it's all fine
and everything like that whereas like I
said the guy is more skeptical and you
have to think he has more reason to be
now one of the oddest things about this
case is that Tony says that he saw Sally
an apparition of her yeah
in the episode and I'm assuming that
this is similar to what happened in real
life it was evidently broad daylight and
he was down in the kitchen like getting
some orange juice or some [ __ ] like that
in the fridge he closes the fridge door
and sees a little girl in a white dress
and a little bow standing there yeah
operations don't mean [ __ ] and
poltergeist real a poltergeist can
appear any way it wants to appear
depending on what your expectations are
it could have appeared to look like the
devil it could appear to look like a
dead ancestor if he was expecting it to
look like a little girl that's what he'd
see yeah now this is what's weird
because this is why I think it was on
paranormal witness too because he drew a
picture of that little girl and it's on
Google I saw and I was like I remember
seeing on a TV show that he dropped him
but it wasn't on the haunting up it may
have been paranormal witness so I think
they did paranormal yes I remember it
yeah but he did draw a picture like what
she looked like and stuff like that like
what he saw and it's kind of funny
because at this point Deb got kind of
mad at him right because she was like
well I'm the one that likes the [ __ ]
ghost why didn't I get to see her why
does she show herself too you know this
sounds like yeah okay so like I said
there's all this little kind of thing
yeah it's just sounded like a bad
situation yeah no because it should be
noted nothing bad really ever happened
to Deb or the baby it was always him it
was always Tony that was getting
attacked which you know that could have
some significance maybe she had like a
lot of deep-seated resentment against
him or something like that she was like
acting out against like you Deb was I
mean because you know not only did he
get scratched and things like that but
one night he claims he was awakened by
someone grabbed
his wrists and jerking him violently out
of bed and at first she was just like oh
you're dreaming or whatever but then he
shows and he says there are blistered
welts on his wrists it just it just
sounds like some opposed right and now
she says oh well why would Sally do that
blah blah and he's starting to think I
don't think this is a little girl I
think there's something else in here me
he even used the D word Hades demons
yeah so they called the psychic back
they didn't say what the psychics last
name was her first name is Barbara room
they call the psychic back and they're
asking that they're like look um Tommy's
getting his ass beat by something and we
don't think it's a little girl so
they're like so can you you know sort
that situation out so she evidently
contacts this Sally person and is like
is there someone else in here now
according to the psychic she says that
there is another entity in the house
that is an older woman who is very
powerful
they don't say she's malevolent
necessarily but they say she's an older
female spirit and that it's not the
little girl so now there's two ghosts in
there yeah and then you know the psychic
says okay well I'm in way over my head
here because I guess you can deal with
one ghost but - that's just see here's
the thing how unlikely is is it to run
into one ghost very unlikely right well
how unlikely is it to run into two
ghosts in the same location yeah I mean
that's like that's like having a
lightning strike twice it's one thing
yeah what they're dealing with one thing
yeah so okay so the psychic says we'll
all put you in contact with someone else
like a whole paranormal team and you
should have a whole paranormal team come
in here and try to see what's going on
so they call in his name's Peter James
right Peter James who is actually quite
a well-known paranormal investigator he
was on like all them shows yeah the
daily Sally Jessy Raphael yeah Peter
James is cool he was back from the tug
from the daytime talk show era yeah he
always seems like it yeah he was it he
was kind of like your standard 1970s New
Age psychic yeah but I'd rather have him
in my house then the Warrens you know
I'm just just gonna say for an approach
she was from a later generation you know
it was like a seventh it was like the
seventies type of thinking which is a
lot more flexible than in Lorraine's
demonology you know where every
everything was a demon and Eddie to come
at you with silver bullets and hemlock
and drink that okay don't drink that and
you know there he do battle with
werewolves and [ __ ] and you know he'd
tell you to move you know huh yeah
you're [ __ ] you have to get out Peter
James like I said he comes in with a
little bit of a crew and they had you
know an actor playing him that actually
kind of look cuz he has that trademark
like white hair and black mustache yeah
so they had an actor that had that too
which I thought with you old-timers
would recognize him if you saw him you
go oh yeah that guy he do you know who
he reminds me of Tom Savini yeah horror
fans you know who Tom Savini is very
famous special effects range Greg
Nicotero a very kind of reasonable
mild-mannered guy you guys oh well you
know these spirits are upset and we're
gonna make we're gonna work it out and
it'll be okay this is your house this is
not their house this is your you're
gonna have to go yeah he's one of those
kinda guys yeah yeah so okay so when him
and his team get there he says he comes
in the house and apparently the first
thing he says he's like I thought you
guys said you only had one kid and it
was a baby and they said yeah we do and
he said well I saw a little girl up in
the window now he says and you know I
know like kind of all psychics and
paranormal investigators say this but he
says he's like I don't want to know
anything about the house for I go there
you know so I can just get impressions
or whatever so he evidently sees a
little girl in the window watching him
yeah and he thought it was a real kid so
he goes in the house and kind of goes
around and does his little psychic key
thing or whatever and he also then even
though he says that he didn't know this
beforehand
he also sees the ghost of a seven year
old girl at the top of the staircase and
he also comes up with the name Sally
even though Deb and Tony said that they
did not tell him that that was the name
caveat but I don't know if that's those
guys they had a tendency of finding out
what the case was before they got
it's like a hot Rheda it's like a no I'm
not gonna say anybody's trying to fool
anybody or trick anybody but it's a
business I do think they have a tendency
to like try to find out some [ __ ] before
they find out some [ __ ] beforehand so I
don't know if he did that or there's a
way most likely there but yeah he says
he did but to his credit is that this
type of psychic when they're doing this
they tend to settle the families down
well yeah that's good they don't make it
worse they try to make it better so I'll
say that in his credit yeah ed Lorraine
Warren will do things that would make it
worse you know maybe they wouldn't try
to make it worse but that's what would
happen yeah because you know and
Lorraine would sensationalize they panic
a family yeah you know it's David you
have to get dude you have to go now it's
after the child it's after the child
right bring in my little [ __ ]
it doesn't really appear like I don't
think anyone told this family that they
were in danger the baby never got hurt
the baby was never in danger nothing
like that
but Peter James comes in and he says so
he sees the little girl Sally now he
goes up to the nursery where it seems
like most of the phenomena was taking
place and he says I feel a very powerful
female spirit in here which is what the
other psychic said and apparently this
female spirit like pushed him out of the
room like he said it's trying to repel
me and they kind of you know how they do
on a haunting with the flashing lights
and all that yeah now also at this stage
evidently they saw scratches appearing
on Tony's back yet yeah common
poltergeist yeah stuff yeah so evidently
so they said they saw that yeah so Peter
tells them okay he's like well he's this
is just what the other psychic said you
have two spirits it's a little girl it's
a woman and the woman is very protective
of the little girl but he says to Tony's
like look this is your house you can't
be afraid of them that just like makes
it worse it's like you have to kind of
put your foot down and stuff like that
now Peter also claimed that he had a
vision in which he saw who these people
were now this is the story evidently
back in the day late 19th century
this house was owned by a doctor and the
doctor had a an african-american servant
who he was apparently having an affair
with right and there was like all these
little whispers and scandal around the
town this is a small town it's Atchison
Kansas for chrissake so evidently the
two of them had a daughter yeah they
were like in a secret marriage yeah yeah
they had a daughter whose name was Sally
and she was seven and she apparently
died of pneumonia in the house and I
should know - I think I forgot to
mention this but the first psychic
Barbara that came the first time she
went up to the nursery she had to leave
because she started to choke all right
now there is one thing I should note
here now this is what it said on a
haunting however if you research the
case other places than that then that
show there's a slightly different
history evidently they say it is true
that the house was owned by a physician
evidently him and his family lived
upstairs and the practice was downstairs
now I have not read any version of the
story where he was having an affair with
the servant and that was their secret
daughter the two versions of the story I
read one of them did concern a girl that
had pneumonia but the girl the girl was
not his daughter it was apparently it
was a kid that was brought there by a
mother who was like you know she's sick
please help her and the doctor could not
help her so the little girl subsequently
died and because she because the doctor
didn't help her she has some kind of
thing against men or something like that
now the worst version of that story is
that the kid actually had appendicitis
yeah and when the mother brought the
little girl to the house the doctor
thought that her appendix would burst
and she was freaking out because she was
in so much pain and he had to hold her
down and he was giving her the ether the
gas and because she was struggling so
much she wasn't completely under
sedation and he started to cut into her
yeah and she flipped the [ __ ] out and
apparently she died on the operating
table and she thought she was being
tortured and that's how she died and it
was very traumatic and she hates men now
that's why she was only an Ave
like I said they got all this evidence
how I don't know it sounds like an
infidelity those are the two stories
I've heard neither of them have to do
with the doctor having an affair with
the son no I'll tell you what those two
stories are embellishments of Peter
James first story yeah that's all they
are they probably will if somebody went
oh yeah well he's a respected psychic so
he must you know but but you know what I
see more than that this is how it really
happens so they're agreeing with him and
disagreeing at the scene yeah because
like I know they say no and chances are
if you're James Version is not didn't
happen either
you'd have you'd have to do an
investigation on that house to see who's
lived there before yeah yeah and and I
guarantee you're not gonna be able to
find anybody matching the description of
that doctor and the yeah that's what I
mean is I saw something that was
invented by the very first psychic that
showed up there the little locals friend
of theirs came up with this there was a
little girl and then there was an older
one it's just a poltergeist it's a
poltergeist case and they're adding to
the story yeah and the poltergeist is
just acting out the characters it's
given yeah that's all this but yeah so
anyway like I said you know but really
what I don't buy it
so research complicated fancy research
around the internet it's like you know
that apparently the house was owned cuz
the house was built like in 18 the 1800s
1870 something like that and apparently
I'm mostly occupied by the Finney family
and apparently one of them was a
physician Charles Finney but um now the
show a haunting said that there was a
little girl named Sally who had lived
there or had lived in the area and that
her grave was still in the area although
they said okay well Bureau records show
that but her grave doesn't have a name
on it anymore because it's worn off
because it's old so you know take that
as you will but there's a lot of Sally's
right that's what I mean so you know
there's no way of knowing that really
unless someone invents a time machine
right and goes back and figures that I
was I was just saying cuz I was curious
when I was researching the show like
around different you know different
various blog things like that
I said I wonder how because I hadn't
seen the episode of a haunting in a
while so I said I wonder if they're
gonna because I didn't remember them
repeating this story
it was one that was like that but it was
similar okay so evidently what Peter
James was saying was that the older
female spirit was actually Sally's
mother the servant and that she was
protective as a little girl and for some
reason did not like Tony because I don't
know why but so Tony is getting his ass
beat and another thing that's been
happening to other than him being
scratched and grabbed and stuff like
that is that evidently Deb says and he
says to that his personality started to
change yeah so he's kind of hinting at
some possession [ __ ] going on all right
that may be and I think he kind of was
implying that maybe he thought there was
something demonic in the house right
because I was messing with his mind he
thought it was mess with his mind
because he commonly reported though yeah
because he started saying that like he
started getting like really angry for no
reason that he started having horrible
thoughts about hurting his wife which
you've never had before things of that
nature
yeah popes are guys sometimes can can
sometimes appear to be possession and
I've also heard stories that people
other than the poltergeist focus can be
affected on an emotional level there was
another case about a couple that would
start fighting each other and they see
like a red haze you know I don't know
when you tell them without that yeah
yeah and they they eventually abandoned
that house because they would just start
fighting each other over a little bit is
she right and it was like something that
was trying to get both of them fighting
which kind of reminds me of that Tim
story from Star Trek remember when they
had the alien red energy getting the
Klingons and that's right it was feeding
off their anger off their anger their
anger yeah well if there was some kind
of entity that did that's what they
would do they would try to like turn
people against each other so they could
yeah on the conflict and everything like
that and there was actually I can't
remember what season it was from but
there was another episode of a haunting
where do you remember that one where
there's some house was supposedly
haunted and it wasn't it wasn't the
raccoon man one it was one where the dad
got kind of like his personality started
to change and remember he came back to
the house went over the dresser yellow
yeah and tried to kill his wife yeah
forgot the name of that episode that was
some Amityville Horror [ __ ] right yeah I
don't even remember the name I don't
even know if we have that once ma yeah I
have it
oh you do I have it he came through the
back door with an axe it was just like
yeah like here's Johnny like here's
Johnny yeah that does seem to be a
common trope on a haunting and I don't
know if that's me every time he went to
jail over that yeah yeah I can't be
bored I have to do that episode two if I
get wrong yeah it's called it wasn't
fear house no like I said they have such
generic titles I can you know hard to
tell apart they're hard to tell apart
like okay I'm gonna have one my episodes
be called ghost house haunted house yeah
that's you might as well yes it's like
oh where demons dwell or where evil
lurks it's like yeah that could be any
episode in the shadow of despair yeah
let's I'm just saying so the only reason
I remember this one is because it had a
name in it forever okay so what did what
happened yeah so so at the end evidently
I think they were gonna try and stick it
out but because Tony was evidently
getting to the point where he wanted to
kill his wife and he didn't really know
why like he felt like something of what
they were doing as to him what was
happening during that time is what's his
name again the site the psychic Peter
James yeah yeah Peter James told them
since that we have to do a cleansing in
this house but to do it we have to have
a full history and we got it prepare for
it it's gonna take some time to get
everything together so stay in the house
and when it's when we're ready to do the
cleansing we'll be back you know the
husband was like oh man I don't wanna go
back in the house ba ba I don't like
this house and then they started
fighting to get within days and he told
her he says this thing's messing with my
mind
Mette it's he's messing with my mind I'm
afraid I'm a hurt you afraid it wasn't
yeah kill you so he says that we got to
get out of here so she was like okay he
asked it out here and they they left
yeah there was and there was a scene
like near the end sorry there was no
cleansing yeah I'd never showed one
maybe that's why people are so
interested in that house maybe yeah
because yeah that's usually how an
episode of a haunting will end like
they'll have the cleansing and Eataly
either work or not I don't remember them
doing it no they didn't because the very
at the end of it was Tony's coming down
the stairs and he's looking at his wife
sitting down there
like all murderous and [ __ ] and then he
apparently gets like knocked over by an
unseen so I don't know if they're
implying that Sally was like hey knock
it off like pushing him or something
like that like to get him to quit it but
I think at that point he was just kind
of over it so he's like you know let's
just get out of here it's not worth it
so they ended up they lived in the house
for 22 months right that's how long they
were there
like I said Deb pikmin did write a book
about it called the Sallie house I
haven't read it but um I read a little
bit of her like talking about it and she
said the stuff they shed on sightings
was kind of exaggerated and not exactly
what happened just from from what I read
of her talking about it sounded like a
haunting mostly got it right she said
now the scratches on his back weren't
that crazy-looking like they were like
super bloody or like that she said you
could see them but they were exaggerated
but yeah that was exaggerated and also
like I said she actually said that that
teddy bear catching on fire she's like
that actually happened more than once
they only showed it once in the show but
um that was kind of a common thing just
very small fires she's like it wasn't a
huge deal or anything like that the kind
of the the main thing that happened a
lot was the toys like being moved you're
sitting in a circle which like we said
that's very similar to [ __ ] that
happened in your yes I'm watching the
whole thing and a haunting is trying to
present this case as a dramatic haunting
involving a ghost and for me it's not
working because it's it's not
manifesting as a typical ghost story or
a ghost sighting usually when you're
doing ghosts it's just the occasional
apparition the ghost doesn't enter isn't
interacting with the person it's almost
kind of like a recording from the past
or you see the apparition of a dead
person who gives you a message from the
other side vanishes turns out that the
message checks out that's a typical
ghost case ghosts don't typically move
objects I've never heard of a ghost
causing pyrokinesis yeah you know I mean
ghost cats always usually I would just
see them you just like see NFC or you
would hear
footsteps so our screams are sad like
that there's a lot of different kinds of
manifestations but usually nothing's
moved
yeah there's usually never anything
worse ting into flames that's always
poltergeist
yeah always pretty much and like I said
and we talked a lot about that on our
pyre Kinesis that Kinetico that we did
and that the story makes a lot more
sense if you if you shoot this story as
a poltergeist story and that's not the
way the episode was shot yeah they seem
to concentrate mostly on the ghost thing
right you know and operating under the
assumption that the ghost was real that
there actually was a little girl that
named Sally that lived there that died
in the house of pneumonia or of
appendicitis or whatever it was so they
did kind of shoot it like that now there
were a few things that the family
reported that were not on the haunting
episode some of them were on the episode
of sightings that they did evidently
there were a lot of cold spots they
actually had a dog which they didn't
show on cold spots is also a poltergeist
yeah the other thing is though is that
this is after the focus is left the
location so I guarantee you who did this
who did that one that was what what team
deciding sightings and now the sightings
show was done while they still live
there oh okay well they still live there
well then that's poltergeist yeah
because we had cold spots at Mammoth
Mountain that's very common yeah like I
said I think that was the first TV show
this may have been they said mid 90s and
the the pikmin family moved out in 95 or
an early 96 summer around there so I so
sightings was done while they still
lived there now like Tony reported cold
spots they also had a dog which they
didn't show on a haunting that would
barking growl at nothing also very
common and apparently the sightings crew
while they were there they supposedly
saw the scratches appearing on the dudes
back as popes filmed it and [ __ ] like
that sound like a broken record yeah I'm
just saying that sound like a broken
record but that's the altar guys it's
not that's not a haunting regular
listeners know what I'm talking about
yeah so evidently after they moved out
of the house
I guess that Tony still had scratches
and [ __ ] like that appearing
periodically after
moved somewhere else but that eventually
it tapered off which again also sounds
like a poultry and and if she if Deb was
the focus like I said maybe she was
acting out some MERS anger anger against
him it's you know she's just she's a
young mother she just had a baby there's
a hormonal factor there
then there's the stress of of the
financial stresses and you know possibly
even like personal stresses between the
husband and the wife that actually
caused frustrations to mount and
psychokinesis starts to happen but yeah
under the control of the right
hemisphere of the brain yeah so it's
it's kind of like acting as a character
out of a dream you can't really control
it but it's open to suggestions if you
tell it it's little kids it acts kind of
like a little kid if it's a demon if
somebody says well it's kind of like a
demon it starts to do things like a
demon the woman wanted it so it was okay
with her the husband didn't want it so
it attacked him yeah okay so there's a
conflict about you know one of them
wants it the focus wants it to stay and
the husband wants it to go so that's
gonna cause trouble now here's an
interesting thing just in in closing
here's an interesting thing that Deb
pikmin says that was actually not
addressed on the sighting show or on a
haunting now she's talking about the
older spirit that she believed the older
spirit that was you know the the kid's
mother now she says and this is a direct
quote the woman was to say the least
very fond of my husband and tried to get
close to him and put great strife
between our husband and wife bond as
reported to me in recent years by my
husband he said that at that time he was
having horrible and uncontrollable
thoughts of hating the mere sight of me
as well as physically hurting me to the
point that I would no longer be a part
of his life so she's kind of saying oh
and she also says later on she says
laying on the couch in a deep sleep one
afternoon Tony sat up looked directly at
me and in a strange voice seemingly not
his own said he's mine hmm then he laid
back down when he woke up 20 minutes
later he couldn't remember anything of
what had happened so she's kind of
saying like
said they didn't really talk about this
on the show she's kind of saying that
this woman was kind of like after her
husband are trying to like cause some
kind of strife in between which to me
suggests what we were just talking about
even more yeah it's her so she's like
she's like in turn saying this female
figure like coming between them yeah and
and he she's inventing an alter ego of
herself kind of like it's a hurt in
isn't that fascinating run that beef I
think the edge wants the husband yeah
yeah I mean and then you know the the it
is hurt and disembodied kind of like
subconscious her subconsciousness and it
kind of like a bad part of her is kind
of like an in a state of astral
projection kind of trying to possess him
and get him to hate her yeah you know
but it's all a game it's just like a
nightmare character come to life that's
all this yeah it's still her yeah you
know when you're having a nightmare you
know I mean right that that character in
your nightmares attacking you well who
is that let's you that's you if you it's
just another version of you and that's
what that thing was yeah great it's just
psychokinesis
like I said otherwise there has been
many many many paranormal groups that
have gone and investigated this house in
subsequent years Ghost Adventures went
there there's like flood it's on a ghost
tour in Kansas and all this other kind
of stuff lots of people said you know
they've felt things that they've had
various impressions in there that they
caught EVPs all this kind of stuff so I
don't know you know I don't want to
definitively say this that the other
thing who knows I don't know I didn't
watch everything about this I didn't
watch all the ghosts to know there's
like I didn't watch all that know like
me my aunt my uncle Wesley and you we go
back to Mammoth Mountain in that same
shot I have been wanting to do that for
ages see if we could ramp that sucker oh
I wanted to happen you have to get it
you have to get in the same one you
remember which one it is yeah what every
model but yeah it's still bad it still
looks the same it's just different
furniture yeah
yeah go in there I want to wonder how
much it cost to rent I don't know and
then get that sucker flow and get it
rolling and then we'll have like we'll
have like you know video cameras and
stuff like that and see if we can catch
anything we need to do that let's let's
start a Kickstarter so we can yeah so we
can go out to Mammoth now and I'm like
ritzy
it is it that will make a mammoth
mountain show I would love to hours of
that I've never been account man maybe
what maybe way at Steve Mara to come oh
that wouldn't happy fun well have Steve
Mara do a Kickstarter to raise the money
forth yeah well I'll go is that because
it's release I think I think I think
that last time I checked it we still you
could rent it or buy it probably rent it
for like two weeks or a week yeah that
would be fascinating yeah totally what a
good idea that yeah all right so anyway
uh were kind of getting to the end of
the show so we hope you guys have
enjoyed our investigation of miss
Sally's house haunting specifically the
episode of a haunting about it like like
I said I read some other [ __ ] about it
too but I can't there's so much about it
that I couldn't get to the bottom of all
of it um so you know if any of you guys
have been there if you're from Kansas
just you know let me know how that goes
and as I usually say if you would like
to support the show in some small way
you can go to our patreon page which is
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast and
give a monthly donation if you would
rather give a one-time donation you can
go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast at wordpress.com and there is a
link in the sidebar to a PayPal account
also check out our last movie review
which was the hand also I know I've been
forgetting to say this lately but go to
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock we have some
five or six different designs of
t-shirts and things of that nature and
that'll do it for episode 67 and we will
see you next week
[Music]
you are at home
[Music]
you
[Music]
you